Russian President
Vladimir Putin
today saying that Russia is training
Belarus pilots to fly combat planes
capable of firing warheads.
The combat's
the comments coming
during a rare visit to Belarus
where Putin
was meeting with his counterpart
Alexander Lukashenko,
who's providing crucial support
for Putin's invasion of Ukraine.
The meeting
coming as fears
grow inside
Ukraine of an imminent invasion
from Belarus.
Nick Paton Walsh is OUTFRONT
Russia's president
makes a rare trip
to his smaller neighbor, Belarus
And the timing has everyone wond
Putin tucking into a local
specially baked bread
has always been
bigger on the world stage,
demanding his towering Belarus
counterparts come and see him.
But was he here is he wants some
he used to?
The problem is
we have certain areas
of military cooperation.
And it's not just supplying each
which in my view,
is incredibly important.
It's also working together
and cooperating as usual.
It's hard to decipher
what the Kremlin head is actuall
But his
forces have been
dropping hints for weeks,
endless public exercises
along the border
between Russia and Belarus and t
not the top tier,
but at the least designed to lea
Ukraine worried.
Kiev's top brass have gone one f
and sounded the alarm
of a full scale
invasion from Belarus in the wee
and late last week, accusing
Russian planes
of flying from Belarus skies
as they dropped the missiles
behind this raid,
which killed a young boy
and three others.
I would also be careful of warns
a rescue here
as is helmet camera footage show
another child pulled from the ru
That relentless Russian targetin
of Ukraine's
infrastructure persisting early
These rare images
claiming to show damage to one f
which as dawn breaks is swamped
fire fighter foam
Ukraine's president saying Monda
Russia had received
250 new Iranian attack drones
likely the shahid loitering muni
but he was sure
to find more emotional reasons
why Ukraine needs arms.
A collage of the Ukrainian child
and their letters to Saint
Nicholas are asking for air
defense weapons, for victory
and for them for all Ukrainians,
They understand everything our c
Let us act
Yet the constant saber rattling
to Kiev's
north on the border
means even less chance of goodwi
For now,
Erin, Putin and Lukashenko
ending their meeting
with a press conference
in which Putin said any speculat
that Russia
is trying to somehow absorb
Belarus into its territory is in
That was roundly mocked
by the State Department.
Putin made some veiled reference
to possibly
the use
of some kind of special weaponry
by Russian
jets, maybe from Belarus in skie
They've been accused of that
last week by Ukraine.
But really mystery,
I think, around
what may come of this meeting.
Certainly Moscow and Minsk
want Ukraine to feel
something is afoot to keep them
whether it comes to fruition
on this very complex battlefield
We'll have to wait and see, Erin